[Music]
welcome everyone to the webinar for
teaching thursdays
how self-isolation impacts teams my name
is stuart creek i'm your host i'm a
marketing manager
at simply learn and my guest today is a
thought leader in project management
jeff allen a bit more about him in a
moment
and i'd like to start if we can with a
two-question poll
the first question is
what's your current team role
and the second is a temperature taking
question
how do you feel today it's on a scale of
thumbs up in the middle or thumbs down
seeing that most people are feeling
pretty good today the thumbs up
and as you can see you have a variety of
different uh roles represented in the
audience today
and again good to see that most of you
are
feeling pretty good about your situation
today
so with that i'd like to introduce
jeff jeff allen is a project management
consultant and trainer
agile transformation coach and he's
conducted more than 325 training
sessions
on various project management
disciplines
certifications techniques and
technologies
prepared more than six thousand people
for certification exams and he is a
faculty member project management here
at simpler learn
welcome jeff thank you i'm glad to be
here
let's uh let's get started with a
question
um we talked last week in teaching
thursdays about the challenges
individuals face and working in
self-isolation
but what special challenges do teams
face
while they're working in self-isolation
scattered all over the place
okay so that's a good question and all
of us have been navigating that
to some degree or another i imagine
and along the way we've discovered that
it comes down to kind of the team
member's
own individual circumstances
and so i thought i would just share with
you what my circumstances are
and then we can build on that as we
start thinking about
how we lead teams and interact with
teams
when everybody's working from home so
i was going to say you got you got
caught in kind of an interesting
situation
it really did so before
anybody really was talking about
the virus situation um
i reported to um a job location
about 2 000 miles from home i live in
utah
and i had a short contract
to do some agile coaching i'm supposed
to go
like six weeks and so i got out
into the washington dc area on february
17th
and then
[Music]
so i was a long way from home and
then my plan was to return home
on march the 21st and
then of course some things changed for
me
one of course is what we all experienced
with the coronavirus situation
and um they the
my client wanted to extend my contract
which meant that it would not be a good
idea for me to travel not knowing
how long we would be working from home
and when
offices might get opened again and so i
was
asked to stay put if i could and my
contract was extended until
the end of june and so right now my
flight home is on july the 2nd
so i have been in the washington dc area
now
for um over two months
and the prospect is you'll be there at
least two months more
yeah it's uh if everything continues as
planned that's what's going to happen
now the project that i'm working on so
that you can get a feel for that
it's a relatively large project we have
11 teams that are working on a scaled
agile project
and for those of us that are new to
project management and agile
agile projects in their inception you
know the concept of
agile project management was small teams
on small projects and now with the
advent
of all kinds of other technology we can
now run these
uh what used to be just small short
well maybe not so short but one team
small
projects we can now scale them where you
have multiple teams working
in an agile way with their output being
aggregated at different points during
the course of the project
this is a distributed project so we have
team members that are based in chennai
and in
washington dc and it's not like there's
a team in dc
or some teams in china every one of the
teams
is distributed with some of the roles
on the teams
in are in washington dc and then
other roles are in chennai so
every team that i'm working with
has an issue with the time zone
uh and so and then because i
am dealing with all of them i have
uh to kind of navigate that
so a day for me often looks like i'm
in a meeting at 3 a.m and then i have
meetings that will run until
mid-afternoon
and then i'm mostly done for the day
it's a relatively complex project that
requires a lot of
coaching from me it's a multi-year
project
it's already been running for over a
year and it started as a waterfall
project and for those of us
that are new to project management those
are the two main approaches to
project management agile or waterfall
waterfall is the more traditional one
where you have big
upfront planning you get everything
baselined and then when you start
working on the executum execution part
of the project and you get your actuals
coming in you compare the actuals to
your baselines and that's how you
determine the health of the project
in an agile environment things are
completed
in short iterations typically
two to four weeks in duration and each
one of those
iterations is kind of like a mini
project
and so um when you have a situation like
i'm
in it's kind of like how do you change
the direction
of a freighter out in the middle of the
sea
that's already got a lot of momentum and
you just have a little bit of push
and so it it takes a lot of effort and a
lot of hands-on
uh coaching
so what happened to me is i was
i'm renting a bedroom in a um a private
residence kind of like an
airbnb situation um it's nice
um it's better than a hotel
um but it's still just one room it's you
know it's got a
private bathroom and all of that and you
can see it's got
a narrow desk that i
set up my initial workspace
at and you know interestingly enough
when i was
packing to come out here for what i
thought was going to be that five or six
weeks
i had this thought that i should bring
two monitors with me
having this conversation in my head why
in the world should i bring two monitors
i i used three at home in my home office
and i got
that it would be helpful to have a
couple monitors but i didn't expect to
be
working from my bedroom i expected to be
going into the office and working
but i've learned that when you get that
kind of inspiration you should usually
yield to it so
i figured out how to take stands off and
pack up two extra monitors
and that was my kind of my original work
at home
where i had a laptop sitting on a laptop
stand and and then two monitors to the
side
and then that's now morphed into
something
a little bit uh different now you can
see i took the painting off the wall
and i'm doing the typical agile
project management using stickies on the
wall i call that uh
my brain on the wall and uh i
borrowed a monitor from
the folks that owned the house where i'm
staying and so i ended up with
three monitors and the laptop off to the
side
connected to a hub so
um you can see that um
whether this was done out from my own
initiative or for working with team
members providing them with the tools
that they need to be productive can be
an enormously helpful thing to focus on
it kind of has nothing to do with uh
the actual work that people need to do
but creating an environment
where they can be productive is huge
so um the equipment that kind of
supports
what i have set up here is um
a chair number one um
my host had given me a um you know there
was like a little side chair
and it didn't have arm rests or anything
like that
and so i actually went to costco which
is a
big box store nearby and i bought a
chair
which has made all the difference in the
world i could
um now effectively work all day like i
would normally do
at um
an office and um
so that that's kind of my environment
now so you you saw the desk the monitors
that kind of stuff
and uh the chair was kind of the thing
that i needed in order to
save my back and be able to work through
the day
and if that yeah i
i just wanted to put a personal note on
that my wife
transitioned to working from home
several weeks after the
the lockdown here started and
she too purchased the chair
for her home office and what she found
she found that a chair she bought which
is very nice
um didn't work for her so she literally
went to her
regular office and took her ergonomic
chair from there and brought it home
so yeah we understand that ergonomics is
a really important
aspect of getting your work done being
productive in
isolation uh yeah
and so and perhaps some of you that are
participating with us have had to kind
of navigate that as well
so you can see that i don't have
the best desk space there it's only
about 15 inches
deep and it's hard to you know ride on
and do things like that
so i did buy a um
uh like a dinner tray tv tray kind of
thing
that i keep off to the side to give me a
little bit more extra space
and uh and then with that chair you know
i'm i'm pretty good
um so that kind of takes us to this
section here
and uh stuart wanted me to uh address
um what are some of the tools that i use
to communicate with my team remotely
keeping in mind that go ahead stewart
i was just saying that
as you pointed out you've got teams all
over the team members all over the world
and the teams themselves are split up
geographically
and so communication coordination
is a huge challenge and we're really
curious about
what tools you use to overcome that
yeah and so i kind of view it as
laying the rails for your productivity
train
because if your folks don't have what
they need to
communicate effectively um
things will grind down to a halt and so
um here's what i have personally set up
here
in my bedroom away from home in
my office away from the office
so there's the equipment side and then
there's the software side
for the equipment um
i have of course my laptop and
my setup ended up being i have a
personal laptop that looks similar to
that and then my client
issued jeff just i didn't hear what you
said stuart sorry
for a second we lost your audio at the
moment that you said that your client
issued you a laptop
can you hear me now you might want to go
back a step
to that i can can you hear me now
okay good so um
what i was saying is that i started with
my own laptop and then i was also
issued a laptop um from work
and that meant that i would be switching
back and forth to some extent
to work on some of my own projects that
i'm always working on even when i have
other assignments and so i did invest
in a docking station this is a
relatively
high-end docking station but it allows
me to
connect up to four monitors
and then it's got an array of usb ports
and
um ethernet if you wanted it and you can
plug in speakers and things like that
and so
what i can actually do is just take
um a usbc cable
out of one computer and plug it into
another and the keyboard the mouse the
monitors
are then attached to that other laptop
so that has been very helpful
your team members may have a situation
like that if not
sometimes a docking station just makes
it
easier because you can have a full-size
keyboard
and a mouse instead of using
the usually smaller and a little bit
more difficult
laptop keyboards and touchpads
this is the keyboard that i got it's
just a
logitech keyboard and
it works great with the nice logitech
mouse
and these are wireless connected to my
laptop through the docking station
and then you saw that i have the
multiple monitor setup
one of the things that is critical is a
webcam and you know what's interesting
was
i wanted to buy
a webcam because i didn't bring one with
me
and they were super expensive
uh relatively high-end webcams that were
normally costing about
99 bucks about 100 bucks had gone
all the way up to 499
and so i actually had one of my sons go
to my house in utah and send me
webcams that i had at home
and of course with all the gadgets um
you know having a usb
hub kind of helps you know bring
everything together
now your team members may not need to
have all of this kind of equipment
but they need to have enough so that
they can be productive and not have to
be fiddling around with
cables and setup and things like that
so again you know when you think about
working with your team
members who are self-isolating think
about yourself what's working for you
to see if you can help facilitate um
them having a similar setup or at least
one that works well for them
so that's kind of the hardware side of
things but that's only the beginning
you also have to communicate and do
work and so there's the software side of
it
and of course um we're using webex right
now
and that's a well-known very stable
robust video conferencing
solution um it's the one that is
offered by my client so when i do
trainings for um simply learn
or you know for my you know doing work
with my client here
um it's all on webex you know
interestingly
i did have a week after i came out here
to the washington dc area
where i had a simply learn
pmp exam prep course which is a four day
course when we do it live
and um the first three days
were done live on site and then that
organization
issued their mandatory work from home
and so the last day of that live
seminar was actually done from this
bedroom
using webex so
not only can you do you know your
regular
work if you have teams and they're
working on a project
but i've proven that you can even do
training
using uh webex and and it went very well
there's other solutions there's zoom
there
is skype there's microsoft teams
uh there's slack so there's you know a
lot of solutions out there for how to
connect
um i'm not doing it now but i've used
um google hangouts meet from
google hangouts and that works well as
long as you don't have too many people
it would still be free now when it comes
to
um how you communicate with
your teams i have found that i needed
some
software that i could use to create
some pictures and annotate them and
share them with
team members because you don't have the
luxury
of you know saddling up next to somebody
at their desk
and demonstrating how to do something or
getting your team together in a
conference room
and showing them how you're going to do
one thing or another
so i use snagit for that and
during the day it's not uncommon for me
to do
seven or eight little snagit images that
i will then
annotate and then email out to
various team members and
i also have another software
solution called camtasia which is
the gives you the ability to create
videos
and so you can record your desktop
while you talk and of course you can say
now
move your mouse over to here and click
here and so
um on this project i'm working on um
we're creating sort of a library
of short two to five minute videos
on how to use software or how to
do certain parts of the project that
would be very difficult
to share just by talking
people through it so that can help
you if you're working with teams
kind of make the training and the
interaction
and the guidance very rich
so software side of things
um also has to include the
project management software that you're
going to use
and there are luckily as you probably
know many different
solutions out there the one that i'm
using
for my consulting contract here
is azure devops
which is a microsoft product and so the
organization that i'm
consulting with is a very large
organization over 25 000 employees
across the world
and so they were already a microsoft
house
and had already settled on microsoft
azure devops
and particularly if you're dealing with
projects
in the agile area this is
an excellent piece of software to use
there are others that are very good jira
i have
some experience with jira as well jarrah
is
a um agile
project management application there are
others there's even some free ones
if you have small projects and and your
budget is tight you can use
trello that allows you to set up
kanban and other views and connect
people and manage a project that way
there's version one there's others out
there
and then there are also waterfall
solutions
one of the common ones is microsoft
project but whatever your solution
is everybody needs to be on the same
solution
and you're going to find that
everybody's going
to need some additional training on how
to do that
back to why maybe something like snagit
and camtasia would serve you well
in assisting your self-isolating team
members
yeah that's a a good point because you
like you said you can't just go up to
somebody's desk and say
say here's how you do it those kinds of
tools for doing
mini demos or remote
teaming like that so very important
let's take a moment here to ask a second
poll question if i may
i'd like to ask the audience members
what team management skills do you
currently use
and there's some of the things that jeff
has
talked about some other things that
relate
collect as many as apply your work
training seems to be
one of the more well used
skills in your not many of you uh
relatively speaking are using scrum
agile techniques currently
meeting facilitation and training are
both important
skills that you're currently using so
let's move on
to you know just to inject something
there
stuart um depending on how
um evolved we are when it comes to
dealing with this work at home situation
we can get better and better at
tailoring
what we do and how we do it because you
know you can have a one-to-one
uh meeting you can have a one-two-many
meeting kind of like a training
and then you can have a many-to-many
which would be like a team meeting
or a brainstorming session so there's
multiple different
skill sets that we'll be getting better
and better at as we
navigate how we deal with managing
projects in this kind of distributed
environment
and i think that you're just about to
talk about that with
you know how you keep projects moving
forward um
when your team is scattered all over the
earth um
this is specifically about as you said
you're working on projects now your
team has a job to do a goal to
accomplish
and so how do you make sure
that the team focus and the team
effort keeps moving in that direction
yeah so um you know there are so many
different ways that we could approach
this i thought i would leverage the
project management point of view
to make some points and to maybe kind of
get our brains
spinning a bit and be creative um
because we could probably do um a whole
seminar on this you know i could do a
day on how to
manage teams and and communicate and
facilitate
meetings um but we don't have the luxury
of that much time
so let me see if i can get us focused um
here quickly
so um this chart right here
is scrum events um or leads up to scrum
events we've got the different
parts of scrum and scrum is a type of
agile project management
but what's really interesting is not the
roles and
things like that which if we you know
we're talking about how to do project
management
remotely we would you know deal with
that but it's the events that i want to
focus on
in scrum you have five
events and what's interesting about
these
they are all time boxed
and time boxing is an interesting
concept
and um i'll talk about that in
a little bit more but i just wanted to
give you an idea that
um not everything that you do
has to look or should look the same
sometimes we're doing planning meetings
sometimes we're doing like daily scrums
those are sync up meetings
reviews is where we're you know
demonstrating what we've done
and getting acceptance or not and doing
retrospectives so there's different
things that we would want to do as we're
working with our teams
and all of these events are what we call
time boxed
okay so um
when you go the time boxing
that leads into the question of how to
stay productive in self-isolation
because
we're not in the same office as our
co-workers our managers our subordinates
and so we don't have those social cues
or vision visual cues or time cues from
the office
and we have to rely on in tools and
techniques for self-discipline so
what what tools do you use yeah thanks
for that question
um so that was a little bit of a clunky
transition but where we wanted to get to
is um share with you the concept of time
boxing
and help apply it to
the project that you might be working on
as well as individually so the concept
of time boxing
is to create a fixed time limit
for a meeting or an event and the rule
is
is that you can end a time boxed event
early
but you never go beyond what the
predetermined duration is going to be
and one of the reasons for that is time
boxing is calculated to change
behavior so if you
have a recurring event and the first
time you do it you don't get
everything completed and so in a way
it's kind of a fail
guess what the next time you have that
same
event you're going to do a lot better
job in order to make sure that you don't
have the pain
from failure the other thing about time
boxing
is it allows you to
increase the focus on whatever it is
you're working on
so if we you know go back to this one
slide right here
um i don't know how many of you are
familiar with um
scrum at all but the the middle one
right there is a daily scrum
and that is a 15 minute sync up meeting
for
the teams team members and
if you don't finish
syncing up with everybody during that 15
minutes you still
end the meeting so that the next time
the team gets together to do their their
uh daily sync up everybody handles a
little bit differently
and so highly focused it's calculated to
change behavior
and when you're in this self-isolating
mode
even if you're not using agile not
working on
agile project the concept of time boxing
can be enormously instrumental in
helping to keep your tone
your team focused and productive
also it can help with
um your own personal productivity
the idea is that in time boxing it
doesn't matter how long the time box is
like i said you just don't ever go
beyond the duration
generally the best thinking is that
you know 15 minutes is the
the shortest duration that makes sense
to do time boxing
and then if you're talking about
a project a project itself could be time
box and so maybe it's a month or maybe a
year
so it's however you want to use the
concept in order to
increase focus and productivity
which i kind of have summarized right
here so time boxing like i said helps
focus attention on whatever it is that
we're working on
and it's going to help the team stay
focused in a unified
way because everybody is directed to
the same thing and it also helps avoid
things called parkinson's lie and
student syndrome
i don't know if you're familiar with
those labels i'm sure you're familiar
with
what they are so parkinson's law says
that works going to expand
to fill the time that's been allotted
for its completion
and so time boxing can overcome that and
then also
student syndrome that's where you delay
doing work
starting work until the last possible
moment
before the deadline so time boxing can
help you
overcome that
it also helps you you know kind of
measure productivity stay on top of it
and by being aware of how much time has
been spent
and how much time is actually available
now one of the things that i've
discovered
not just with my team members but with
myself
and that's what do i do to get a
breakthrough when i'm kind of stuck
i don't know if any of you are like me
but there have been times when
i will have like a week of stuff to do
and i'll get ready on monday morning and
i don't really know
where i'm going i'm disorganized and so
i have found that in a kind of a
ritualistic way if i
set up some events for myself not just
the project but for myself
i'm going to be a lot more productive
so i like to do a weekly
planning session for myself where i kind
of envision
what i want the week to end up having
looked like
and then of course you know daily
planning
is enormously important
and then at the end of the week to do
what
you know borrowing a project management
term a retrospective
which is really simple it's basically
asking yourself three questions you know
what worked well during the week
what didn't work well during the week
and what am i going to do differently
going forward
you know another way to say that is when
i get what am i going to keep doing next
week
what am i going to stop doing next week
and what am i going to
um keep doing did i say that right but
am i going to stop what am i going to
start and what i'm going to
keep doing and then also something
that's enormously critical
is to build in breaks during your day
[Music]
i have found that it's easier
to stay in my chair for
longer periods of time while i'm working
from this bedroom here
than when i was at the office and maybe
it's because at the office you had a
reason to go
talk with somebody or whatever but i
have found
that my mind gets muddled and i
get sluggish if i don't deliberately
choose to take some breaks
and then i don't know if you've had this
situation um
where you've gone in to your your work
space
and you know like maybe you've got this
pile of things that
you know needs your attention and you
look at that pile
and and you don't even know where to
start and
you're kind of getting stressed out
because you know you have too much to do
not enough time to get it done and you
can't even figure out what
what to start with so one of the things
that i have
come to value is doing what we could
maybe call as a personal time box bike
and what this looks like is
me getting my phone out and going to the
timer app
and setting the timer for 15 minutes
and what i'm telling myself is is for 15
minutes
i can focus on something so just take
the
thing that's on the top of the pile and
just for
15 minutes do nothing else
um i have also done it using you know 30
minute timers depending on kind of
how the day's rolling and whether i'm
able to kind of
you know get a pattern interrupt and
start focusing better than i was before
i've even done um one hour spikes where
i
literally set a timer and when this
timer is running
there's no email there's no phone calls
there's no texting there's no messaging
all that stuff is ignored or put out of
the way
so that you're focusing only on what's
at hand and i have repeatedly benefited
from that and getting that breakthrough
to kind of get myself
going during the day and it's something
that
um i've done some coaching and mentoring
with others
and and it works well for them
also now
i was going to say one thing that came
out of last week's teaching thursday
also is the
notion of setting the boundary between
what's work time
and what's personal time and this
concept of a personal time box spike
relates to that and that you're you're
talking about setting
a defined period of time that is work on
a given task
and setting that boundary so that other
things don't intrude on that
which is kind of the flip side of
setting the boundaries on personal time
so that work doesn't intrude on that
so those those concepts work together
very well
i love that and um you know if we are
in an environment where we have children
at home who can't go to school
right now um they need our attention
and being able to literally
create a time box um for a break or to
spend some family time
where you can genuinely focus on
family or kids or whatever is enormously
beneficial
you know it's you know we need that and
of course our family needs that and so
there's going to be a higher level of
harmony which also means that you're
going to be more productive
now um part of what we're doing is
conducting online meetings and i just
wanted at a really high level to just
share a couple of things that i have
learned
again we could spend a whole day on how
to
do online meetings but the number one
thing is
whether it's you you or someone else
make sure someone is designated as a
facilitator
that has skills to be a facilitator
and have someone designated to be the
scribe for the event
avoid almost at all costs having the
facilitator
also be described particularly when
we're in this online environment it's
very difficult to be focusing on content
and you know navigating
the meeting and steering it in the right
direction and also
keeping your eye on the chat box and
taking notes
almost impossible and just a couple tips
that might help
your meetings be more successful
is have the facilitator start by
establishing ground rules
phones off you know whatever it might be
and you can do this in a collaborative
way so everybody
is contributing to what that meeting is
going to look like
here's a really big one you've got to
slow down on our online meetings
it's not like being in a room with 10
people where
you know in just a second you can scan
everybody's faces
and kind of get a read on their eyes on
whether they're with you or not so
you've got to slow down
and you've got to ask questions and
you've got to be
listening for what is not what's being
said but
the message that's being sent making
sure you
understand that and then because we're
separated it becomes even
more important to come to consensus when
we're having meetings
so that when you're finished with the
meeting your objective is
everybody can walk out of that meeting
saying i can live with that
the decisions that we made that's
a really uh great overview of
how to keep meetings focused and
meetings are
essentially you know the way we're going
to be interacting online
um you know the the concept of
well we can just walk over to the other
guy's desk
or get a few people together quickly
is a lot less viable now
and the idea of putting together formal
meetings and running them
um in a way that keeps them
productive and moving and achieves that
consensus that you talked about
it's so very important when we you're
working in a distributed motion
so the last question i have for you is
what long-term
impacts do you see the crisis having um
once we're out of isolation and
are allowed to go back to
something closer to normal what do you
think the
the your effects will be
yeah of course nobody really knows for
sure what that's going to end up looking
like
but we're all pretty confident that
it's not going to be like it was before
and
and i don't know if you've done what
i've done but
i have actually read a little bit about
it
and listened to a couple other webinars
that specifically
are addressing um you know the aftermath
of this whole crisis and so i thought i
would just
share with you a couple of the things
that i picked up on
um and again this is you know a little
bit more like just
you know getting our brains thinking and
being prepared
for whatever it might end up being
you know one of the things that
many people are talking about is there's
going to be a significant increase in
unemployment
in the united states of course that's
already happening
i expect it's happening in other parts
of the world as well
um and also there's going to be a lot
more
um remote working going on
um i have noticed that
it's a little bit of a mixed bag
kind of a two-edged sword i find that a
lot of my team members are actually
working
longer than they were when they were at
the office
and so i have to be concerned about you
know their you know long-term
productivity
um but the other side of it is is that
you know i've been on meetings you know
when
you can hear babies crying in the
background
but regardless of the downside of remark
remote working it's going to be much
more common
so a couple suggestions that go along
with
what we're facing or going to face one
is
you know ramp up our networking you know
um be talking to people
you know emailing whatever it is you
know work your network
which related to that would suggest
let's keep our
social media profile um up to date
and maybe even improve it um
linkedin i have gotten a lot of business
off of linkedin from people
i don't know because you know they saw a
connection and they checked it out
and you know maybe caused them to do a
search on
youtube and see some of the training
videos that i've done that are out there
so you know you don't have the
the lunches and the other get-togethers
that we used to have and so we've got to
network and
use social media a bit different and
then
you know we could all get bad news
and need to find a job i've had it
happen
and so one of the things that would be
smart
is to spend some time
making sure you're spruced up on your
interview skills and i actually have
a mistake here the other box here should
be
get your resume updated and make sure
that that's
ready to send out uh because if
you do have that unfortunate event
in your life happen um
you're not going to be the only one
there's going to be a lot of other
people that are dealing with it and so
your advanced preparation on
having your resume up to speed and your
interview skills
at their best is going to be critical
and kind of along those lines
do what you can to stand out in
whatever circles social media circles or
other circles that you might be a part
of
because again you know there's going to
be
a lot of folks that are going to want to
be doing what you need to do
as well which leads me to
something that is often overlooked and
that's to be deliberate
in working on improving soft skills
you know i used to think that leadership
and communication
and some of these other soft skills
you're either born with
or you or you just you know
missed out on it i have since learned
that you can
with deliberateness improve your soft
skills
and you know when you're working from
home like we are now
um there's plenty of time to you know
kind of carve out
and practice uh carve time out and
practice those skills even it's with you
know
family members and then of course
this one's going to be huge it already
is
and that's to get certified in one or
more different areas
if you are not already or even if you
are
add some additional certifications
um you know i'm not a huge fan of
standardized testing as being a
predictor for
uh real life performance but what i can
tell you is
it's still the best way to set yourself
apart
uh by getting some initials after your
name
um you know the skill side you know
working on
cleaning up or learning how to do active
listening
and it looks like i have my box here
that i meant to have on the other
screen and that's to clean up your
resume
and then in particular work
on your facilitating techniques
how do you conduct meetings how do you
take
people that have strong personalities
and work your magic so you can get
everybody under the same page
even when you are working remotely
now i come from the project management
world and
i'm not sure if you do or not but for
those of us that do
live and work in the project management
world
i wanted to share with you a couple of
the certifications that i think
carry the most weight when it comes to
getting a job keeping a job and having
a career path that will be not just
satisfying but monetarily rewarding
so the number one project management
certification in the world today remains
the project management professional the
pmp
um and that is at least until the end of
the year still
waterfall focused at the end of the year
it changes there's a significant change
coming
with the pnp and so if you've ever
thought about getting your pmp
get it now before the end of the year
the the exam is changing
in content the types of questions
it's going to be a blend of waterfall
and
agile and hybrid agile so there's a
whole ton of uncertainty about what it's
going to look like to actually pass the
exam and get your pmp
so a word to the wise i've been through
some of these
changes with the pmp certification
um get done now if that's on your radar
screen
now i'm also of the opinion than the
project management world that
you need to understand and be skilled
in not just waterfall but also agile
most projects these days end up being
hybrid projects with a blend of
waterfall
and a blend of agile and so you've got
to somehow
make it clear that hey not only am i
waterfall i've got my pmp
but i'm also agile i have my acp or
something like my asm the asm and the
acp
are kind of similar
the but the scope is a bit different you
know asm
includes transition things like how do
you
you know go from waterfall to
um agile
and the asm also is more focused just on
scrum
the acp is broader you're going to get
exposure
and testing on a broader array of agile
approaches and practices so either one
is good
but i would recommend you know if you're
going to be in project management
get the pmp get the acp um or the pmp
and the asm
or get all three for that matter
so that um basically
uh jeff's presentation um we're going to
go through
a quick poll here to uh
cap off before we get to question and
answer
and the question in this poll is which
team management skills are you most
interested in learning
you can select as many as apply to you
so with jeff's admonition in mind that
you need to stand out
and make yourself
more valuable in an uncertain world
which skills are you looking to acquire
certifications that type of thing
i can see that pmp and agile are
very popular selections among this
audience so the most
uh popular choices in this audience as i
said are pmp and
agile and some interest in scrum as well
and even kanban so
can i make a comment sure absolutely
you know that doesn't surprise me that
that's uh the results of the poll and
if um i may make a suggestion
if you are interested in more than one
start with the pmp for that reason i was
just talking about
with the the fact that the exam is
changing
um so i would elevate that um i do teach
the pmp
for simply um um
so if they if you want to do that you
want to ask for me they can maybe talk
me into doing that
but at one point i had trained um one
percent of all the pmps in the whole
world
so if you take one of my pmp classes
you'll be a pmp
that's great so i think at this point
we're moving on to the
q a section of our presentation
and we have a few questions from the
audience for you jeff
pull up okay question sheet uh
somebody had a quick question um do you
use a touchpad pen on your pc
it's one of your tools
no um i'm clumsy at that
so i don't like it so i always go for a
mouse
like even my work laptop um
i bought a mouse just to use with the
work laptop
um so how do you know
if your team has everything they need to
work effectively
i think you're bold and you ask directly
and ask probing questions you know
what's your chair look like
you know what's the longest you've sat
in your chair um
what's your internet connectivity like
you know right now just go ahead do a
speed test let's see what it's like
so i would be bold
in drilling down on specifics on some of
the things that we talked about with
respect to equipment
and their knowledge on how to use
whatever software solutions you're using
thanks um we have a related question
from a list or audience member in the
philippines
um it's how do you be productive if you
don't have a strong internet
apparently is the difficulty for them
i don't have a good answer to that
yeah are there are there workarounds
like using um
uh hotspot on your phone or that type of
thing or is that
gonna work well if you're if you're in
yeah if you're in a geographical region
where the internet's not good um the
likelihood that you could
uh use your phone to get internet
like productivity speed isn't very high
i have team members you know in the
project i'm working on where they're
in parts of the world that
aren't fully developed that way and
it's it's impacting performance there's
no way around it
but that but recognizing that of course
you know you can uh be empathetic and
help them work through the pain
and maybe there will be things that will
emerge
as
you know things go forward but that's a
problem i don't there's not a great
workaround
um question about whether
uh recruiters at this point are being
given enough time to go through resumes
and is this
the right time to send resumes by email
absolutely i would be
all over that if you're in a situation
where you need a job
i would push every lever you can
think of sending out emails
you know going to these employment
websites
identifying headhunters that might be
able to help
um in the environment that we're in
right now
it's gonna be um the shotgun approach to
get started
great um we have a question i think i'll
go ahead and address which is you know
some people asked about some free
certification
or free education courses and i know
that the present time simply learn is
offering
a number of its basic courses for
free mainly through the android
mobile and up but check our website for
that you can also check our website for
discounts that we're running at the
present time to help people
on our uh certification and training
courses
so i think that's all the time we have
for questions hey stuart i might just
mention
something um he's been around the block
a long time going around the block a
long time when it comes to training and
certification
the best learning management platform
i have ever dealt with is simply learn
so i mean you can do uh
live classes you can do online pace
yourself classes you can do blends of
those
the um testing you know the practice
testing platform
is awesome and you can even
um sign up for classes where you have
access to materials for
several months it's not like hey a four
day thing and then you know
either you get it done or you don't
so i am a faculty member
at simply learn but i also am a faculty
member with
other organizations as well and nobody
comes close to simply learn
when it comes to their online learning
management system thank you for that
endorsement jeff um we like to think so
are you able to advance the slide
i think i can
let me try again here we go yeah one
more
there you go okay and here we go
so um jeff if you'd like to
thank the audience and give your answer
oh yes
contact absolutely so
um first of all team thanks for taking
time out of your day
and um excuse me
um you can find me on linkedin and
i would be happy to engage with you and
share any guidance i might have
so you can find me just jeff allen on
linkedin
and um be happy to
be of assistance in whatever way you
would like
okay and um thank you jeff everybody
please join us
uh next thursday and the thursday after
for our teaching
thursday's webinars next thursday
we'll have ronald van loon talking about
how
self-isolation affects doing data
science work
and the following thursday may 15 may
14th i should say
how self-isolation impacts a digital
marketing career
that's with our matt bailey and please
do
connect with simplylearn on our
platforms
facebook twitter linkedin
and feel free to contact us with any
questions
we'd be glad to help you get the
certifications you need to
move forward in these uncertain times
that concludes our webinar thank you
again
look forward to helping you soon